1er mai en ordre dispersé sans succès
pour les syndicats français sont nés en
demi-teinte reportage à paris et en
régions 1er mai politique et polémique
pour jean marie le pen opposés au projet
de loi contre le racisme le leader du
front national menace d'appeler ses
militants à la désobéissance 1er mai du
désaveu et de lascaux cours mihai
gorbatchev qui a dû quitter la tribune
sous les cris et les sifflets hostiles
des manifestants
enfin 1er mai est risqué pour les
tourterelles et allain bougrain dubourg
fortement bousculé dans la région de
bordeaux par des chasseurs amoureux de
la tradition
bonsoir fin d'un symbole du moins en
occident il ya cent ans le 1er mai
c'était la fête du travail c'était le
jour des ouvriers aujourd'hui les
ouvriers sont à la plage ou à la
campagne
avènement d'un symbole dans les pays de
l'est jusqu'à présent le 1er mai a
toujours été la fête officielle
la fête du parti unique et les ouvriers
se taisait aujourd'hui les ouvriers
parlent ils protestent eux mêmes et
n'hésite pas à conspuer le tout puissant
maître du kremlin
nous le verrons dans un instant avec nos
envoyés spéciaux à brusque ou à chacun
son anniversaire cent ans plus tard là
bas en fait la liberté retrouvée
ici il a plutôt l'air raqueter
manifestations populaires à paris et en
province pour la cgt réunion et contact
ce matin avec les syndicats des pays de
l'est pour force ouvrière et table-ronde
pour la cfdt ce soir les syndicats ont
fêté le centenaire du 1er mai en ordre
dispersé fêter c'est un bien grand mot
la mobilisation était en effet plutôt
faible samuel costa à paris la cgt a
choisi la rétrospective pour célébrer le
centenaire du 1er mai avec 10 à 15000
personnes entre nation et république
des banderoles ont évoqué les
manifestations du 1er mai 1906 le front
populaire de 36 la libération et les
acquis de la sécurité sociale aux côtés
d'henri krasucki des délégués d'afrique
du sud de nouvelle-calédonie des cubains
des palestiniens des latino américains
un 1er mai éclectique tout comme les
slogans qui réclamaient la fin de
l'apartheid le smic à 6500 francs
l'abandon de la réforme ptt et la
poursuite des activités des usines
renault à billancourt
une idée forte assemble les travailleurs
du monde entier
qu'est ce que tu as le même jour quand
leurs intérêts et leurs idéaux
qui les rassemble
de son côté la cfdt et la faim ont
préféré un 1er mai sous forme de
rencontre qui démarre en ce moment même
au cirque d'hiver
pour la cfdt les grandes manifestations
global ayant pour objectif de fêter le
1er mai ne correspondent plus à la
réalité
un spectacle avec bashung aura lieu ce
soir
une journée que la centrale syndicale
aurait souhaité fêter avec fo cftc et la
cgc qui ont décliné l'invitation
un centenaire du premier mais sans union
syndicale est aussi sans enthousiasme
débordant
si ça c'est qu'il y à un peu plus d'une
heure une brève échauffourée a eu lieu
en quête de défilés du 1er mai de la cgt
une trentaine de militants anarchistes
se sont heurtés aux forces de l'ordre
bilan trois blessés le défilé du front
national aujourd'hui a commencé sur un
air de famille les petits enfants du
leader était là il s'est terminée sur
une aire de combat
les petits enfants du leader était
toujours là daniel sportiello oublier le
temps sauf que du congrès de nice où
jean marie le pen s'était payé le luxe
de ne pas faire un carton sur
l'immigration pour ce 1er mai consacré à
jeanne d'arc figure de proue du front
national parce qu'à la bouteille
l'étranger en de france le président du
front national a retrouvé la virulence
des grands jours
il faut dire que le climat était propice
et les militants demandeurs voté pour et
l'étrange heures de france
dans un décor taillé pour lui sur mesure
jean marie le pen s'en est pris aux
pouvoirs prêts à violer les principes de
la république dit il
lisez la proposition de loi communiste
sur la répression du racisme que les
députés examinent demain elle prévoit
une peine d'interdiction des droits
civiques en cas de diffamation ou
d'injure raciale
ce qui donnerait le droit de vote aux
étrangers alors qu'on le retire et aux
patriotes estime jean marie le pen qui
brandit alors la lourde menace de
l'incivisme
j'appelle en même temps qu'à la
vigilance et à l'action j'appelle à la
discipline nationale tous nos militants
qui si besoin était recevrait les ordres
que leurs dirigeants lors donnerait qui
se souvient pas s'il estime que ce n'est
pas le racisme que le pouvoir entend
réprimer mais le patriotisme français
jean marie le pen vient de franchir un
pas de plus reste à savoir quelles
seront les réactions de la classe
politique précisément pas de réaction
pour l'instant mais la déclaration faite
par jean pierre façon avant le défilé
prend du coup un certain relief et
ancien responsable du père et animateur
du mouvement la france unie le ministre
du travail affirme est en effet ce matin
que les centristes devait choisir entre
l'alliance avec le front national où
l'entente avec le parti socialiste dans
les coûteux de suite surtout front
national je n'accepte pas que ce londres
on lui laisse le base et de paris un 1er
mai et qu'elle 1er mai pour le
centenaire
ce qui veut dire que l'opposition aura
un choix clair à effectuer entre
l'entente avec le parti socialiste où
l'alliance avec le front national et
lorsque j'ai fait moi-même le choix de
l'ouverture en juin à 88
j'ai choisi l'entente avec le parti
socialiste
je souhaite demain que mes amis du décès
et de l'udf comprendre comprennent que
l'intérêt du pays et le faire le même
choix et donc de choisir
l'entente avec le parti socialiste la
liberté que mikhaïl gorbatchev a voulu
dans son pays prend désormais pour lui
un goût plutôt amer à moscou ce matin le
défilé officiel du 1er mai n'aura duré
qu'une heure et demie le temps pour mira
et gordeychuk de voir défiler devant lui
du mouvement réformateur
ultraconservateur le temps pour le
numéro un soviétique de se faire siffler
et huer par des manifestants hostiles au
régime
un affront quand gorbatchev n'a pas
supporté il a quitté ses la tribune tout
de suite la correspondance de notre
envoyé spécial à moscou hélène risacher
pâte soit pas d'épater pouvoir sur la
place suivi par toute la délégation
officielle de politique par personne
mais l'opposition progressiste leur
manifestation a été autorisée après le
défilé officiel des syndicats en début
de matinée avec 57 personnes le 1er
dauphine et solidaire organisé pour la
première fois par les syndicats
n'avaient pas été imprimé quelqu'un bat
sauf en garde contre sa politique de la
scène économique contre les menaces de
chômage qui est le magasin de prison
président
la voiture n'est pas avec ce nom chômage
ainsi du côté des syndicats proches des
conservateurs de nouvelles réformes
liberté également retrouver en roumanie
où l'opposition ne désespère pas de
stabiliser de déstabiliser le nouveau
pouvoir qui l'accuse de connivence avec
les anciens communistes le reportage de
philippe pisteurs et de marque d'eau
mieux vaut s il ya une queue dictateur
mugron et repas gabo traître que vaut
être voyez plutôt qu'activer mort que
communiste
première fête du travail libre en
roumanie rien à voir avec les grands
meetings des années précédentes
soigneusement organisé à la gloire de
chercher squid police le 1er mai ici
ensemble ou jours précédents une fête de
la contestation la place de l'université
occupée depuis neuf jours maintenant par
des manifestants anti gouvernementaux au
rhum permanent on chante on discute on
use or le tout dans la dérision
depuis qu'il y ait ce coût a traité les
manifestants de golan de voyous le mot
est à la mode
nous lui montrons que nous sommes des
voyous mais des voies utilisées
il ya là des étudiants des travailleurs
des intellectuels tous sont des voyous
réel aux membres plus de communistes
mais y croire que l'actuel régime et le
fond de la scène est une émanation de ce
qui est il le désire
et moi je ne suis pas satisfait de cette
idée chaque ouvrier doit premièrement
connaître la vérité et après réfléchir
collage fleuri sur tout et poitrine
il y en a de toutes les sortes 17il
colan du golan qui s'affine et golan de
luxe
et même des goals and the race est
derrière l'humour il y a les
revendications l'émission violent des
scoops report des élections
interdiction aux anciens responsables
communistes de s'y présenter
mézino commencé mais prendre le
caractère bon enfant où l'on explique de
cette manifestation ici à bucarest
s'engage et un climat électoral negra
déjà hier signé une déclaration commune
menaçant de boycotter les élections si
leur sécurité n'était pas assurée
n'oublions pas les autres pays où le 1er
mai a été célébrée de diverses façons
des dizaines de milliers de manifestants
à berlin où les syndicats de l'est et de
l'ouest se sont unis pour les défilés
pas de manifestation revanche à pékin le
gouvernement y étaient hostiles
et c'est sans conteste dans les pays de
l'est que le centenaire du 1er mai a été
le plus fêté lance piqué berlin-ouest
soixante mille personnes réunies pour la
première fois depuis 44 ans par les
syndicats de l'est et de l'ouest
retrouvailles sous le signe de
l'inquiétude c'est du chômage dans une
allemagne unie atmosphère bon enfant
dans la plupart des pays d'europe de
l'est ce oublier les défilés obligatoire
à budapest kermesse populaire et pique
nique organisé par le parti communiste
orthodoxe et par le parti socialiste
même programme en tchécoslovaquie où
l'on à renouer avec les fête
estudiantine célébré pour la dernière
fois en 1968 en bulgarie quarante mille
sympathisants de l'opposition dans les
rues de sofia
dix mille personnes ont manifesté sous
les bannières de l'ancien parti
communiste en turquie comme l'an dernier
les manifestations étaient interdites
plus de 380 personnes interpellées à
istanbul
les affrontements ont fait 14 blessés un
algérie rassemblement de dix mille
personnes environ sous la pluie
les femmes ont protesté contre la
ségrégation enfin images violentes de ce
1er mai en corée du sud
des milliers d'étudiants s'attaquer la
police anti-émeute des bagarres dans
presque toutes les villes du pays
les étudiants protester contre la
répression antisyndicale du gouvernement
les quatre français pris en otage hier
au congo seront sans aucun doute libéré
et n'ont pas été enlevés pour des
raisons politiques le commando armé l'a
fait pour couvrir sa fuite
quant aux otages américains du moins
ceux qui sont encore détenus
leur sort dépend de la bonne volonté de
l'iran et ce soir l'iran menacé de ne
plus poursuivre sa médiation entre
guillemets dans la crise des otages
en l'absence d'une contrepartie
américaine les simple remerciement de
george bush i reçoit après la libération
de frank reid n'ont pas suffi mais
washington campe sur ses positions pas
de rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques tant qu'il y aura des
otages américains
dans le même temps frank reid gut est à
ses premiers instants de liberté depuis
trois ans et demi émotion mémona
hintermann sur cinq fois quid arrive à
l'hôpital america de wiesbaden
ces images sont étonnants cet homme doit
avoir une force de caractère
exceptionnel il a passé quarante trois
mois en détention absolue les yeux
bandés le manifestement il n'a pas dû
laisser son esprit sorte raisonnée et sa
volonté ne s'est pas brisée contre le
désespoir car rarement on a vu un otage
qui vient d'être libéré aussi solide
moralement il dirigeait une école
internationale au liban il allait à une
partie de golf quand il a été enlevé à
beyrouth ouest le 9 septembre 1986 il y
a deux jours une organisation inconnue
l'aube islamique
annoncer sa libération george bush a
reçu à la maison blanche robert boyle
l'otage libéré il y a dix jours le
président américain a remercié sobrement
la syrie et l'iran pas d'hommage appuyé
comme celui de la face à la libye les
valence l'amérique c'est clair ne fera
aucun geste à l'égard de l'iran
tant que les six autres otages
américains au liban des sons pâtir il
est mort le poète parce qu'il était
aussi poète antoine vitez n'avait que 59
ans et toute la famille du théâtre se
sentent aujourd'hui orpheline
dominique poncet toute la comédie
française à la douleur de vous annoncer
de mesures antoine hubert administrateur
général de la comédie française vient de
décéder aux allemands à le regarder
on pouvait penser que cet homme n'était
que ces vérités ascétisme et enfermement
mais tout ce qu'il avait rencontré savez
bien que cette austérité physique
n'était qu'apparence antoine vitez
c'était en fait l'une des lumières du
théâtre français et pas peur des
comédiens j'ai pas peur de la compagnie
j'ai pas peur
comédie française j'ai pas peur de faire
du théâtre le tout est de faire du daf
et pour exercer cet art sur les hauteurs
que l'on sait il avait appris en
emprunter tous les chemins il savait
écrire il savait traduire le grec
l'allemand et le russe
il savait aussi enseigné brillamment
disent aujourd'hui ses élèves qu'il
pleure et bien sûr il savait aussi jouer
il mettre en scène en tout il nous aura
offert plus de 60 production parmi les
plus lumineuses de ces vingt dernières
années
antoine vitez c'était le symbole du
théâtre intelligence était sans doute
l'homme qui savait le mieux décortiquer
un texte et cela faisait quand suite sur
un plateau leur ampleur devenait
magnifique
écoutez le parler de galles idées sa
dernière mise en scène me trouble
également chez moi dans un monde qui est
à la fois le monde le monde des amis de
mes amis
et puis aussi dans le monde des idées
qui me sont proches qui me sont
familiers
c'est à lui qu'on devait ce slogan qui
illustrait bien sa démarche tout plein
d'exigence un théâtre élitaire pour tous
une formule qu'il avait inventé
lorsqu'il avait pris en 1981 les rênes
du théâtre de chaillot
il n'y avait pas deux ans qu'il était à
la comédie française
le temps lui aura vraiment manqué pour y
imprimer sa marque
il est rare qu'un homme face à ce point
l'unanimité c'était le cas d'antoine
vitez jeu de l'état qui s'est déclaré
trés affiché de très affligée par don de
son côté jacques lang pleure un frère et
un ami
tristesse aussi pour georges marchais où
jacques chirac et blanc la disparition
d'un inventeur de langage et de gestes
très vive émotion évidemment aussi dans
le monde du théâtre
voici tout de suite quelques réactions
recueillies par michel vial ce dont je
me souviendrai longtemps probablement
enfin toute la vie d'acteur qu'il me
reste à faire c c'est cette approche de
la langue française pour laquelle il
avait un amour infini une compréhension
très grande île à travers cette rigueur
de de l'analyse de la matière textuelle
chute hier il était capable de nous
donner une liberté infinie
ce qui permettait à des textes aux
textes du passé d'avoir une une présence
immédiate pour le public d'aujourd'hui
c'était à la mi c'était un citoyen et
puis je crois une sorte de magistrats
paix tic et de prince démocratique du
théâtre et c'est un cours des liens un
coût des liens athée mais il en sortait
tout ce qui sortait le sens le sens des
mots celui qui vient de disparaître
c'est un camarade d'utopie les théâtres
qui l'utopie le communisme est une
utopie et je crois que lui et moi nous
avons cru en ses deux utopie et nous
continuons d'y croire et d'y travailler
malheur à ceux qui aiment les
tourterelles allain bougrain dubourg l'a
encore appris à ses dépens pour la
deuxième fois consécutive le défenseur
très médiatique des oiseaux a voulu
faire respecter un décret européen
interdisant la chasse à la tourterelle
mais pour la deuxième fois consécutive
aussi allain bougrain dubourg s'est
orthez aux chasseurs qui veulent
défendre une tradition
l'animateur il y a perdu des plumes
reportage fr3 bordeaux bernard bonnet
edonys des us
quatrième barrage à soulac
infranchissable comme les autres le plus
dur un peu avant midi malgré les élus
présents malgré les gendarmes nombreux
allain bougrain dubourg est violemment
prise à partie
shampoing aux oeufs ne crever il se
réfugie dans sa voiture sous très haute
protection
l'histoire semble bégayer en médoc il ya
des élus locaux qui cautionnent cette
situation je le regrette maintenant une
situation qui me dépasse nous on était
dix élèves exciter les gens violents des
gens agressifs on vient simplement
présenter la situation aux
parlementaires européens
on vient constater que la loi n'est pas
appliquée en france
les chasseurs appuyé par les élus locaux
ont donc réussi
le président de la lpo et les
parlementaires européens qui
l'accompagnent n'irons pas jusqu'à la
pointe de grave
tout avait commencé très tôt ce matin
avant laisse par un premier barrage
qu'il avait fallu contourner et déjà le
producteur de télévision et mis en garde
nous pensons que ce bouquin du bourg
aura la sagesse pour gagner bordeaux de
ne pas entretenir un climat de guerre
deux complices c'est lui qui retient le
climat de guerre le conflit
il refait chaque année c'est
certainement un coup médiatique qui
recherchait et dont ne sont pas là pour
ça du côté des chasseurs à la
tourterelle de printemps la consigne est
claire et chez les journalistes
l'agressivité vous donc comprenez bien
que dans des situations comme ça
longtemps marié à dire c'est tout
le tirage tourterelles reprendra demain
matin à 7 heures le médoc n'est pas très
européen
on aimerait bien avoir la vie et des
tourterelles laventure c'est bien la
prudence c'est mal cette semaine et
auront failli ne plus revoir le jour
heureusement ils sont sains et saufs les
sept spéléologues dont on n'avait plus
aucune nouvelle depuis hier matin sont
sains et saufs
ils ont été retrouvés par une équipe de
80 sauveteurs bloqué dans une partie de
la grotte de la grotte bodin sans vivres
et sans équipements sophistiqués ils
sont épuisés
reportage fr3 besançon s'il a fait plus
de deux jours que les sept belges n'ont
pas vu la lumière dimanche 16h30 ils
descendent dc du gouffre du gué booster
leur objectif est de parcourir toute la
galerie
pour ressortir à la grotte baudoin un
parcours d'une dizaine de kilomètres
le groupe en détresse déjà voulu qu'elle
est privée ou dans la région mais c'est
la première fois qu'ils explorent le
réseau du vernon mais selon leur amie
qui a donné l'alerté
il allait bien préparer leur sortie et
son expérimenté coup d'être ensemble ils
ont eu des renseignements il faut pas
partir
les secours ont été déclenchés lundi à
19h et ses 20 heures plus tard ils ont
été retrouvés sains et saufs par des
styles et aux plongeurs à 800 est
derrière nous pour l'instant ils sont
faux ils sont bien installés on l'aura
monter une tente on leur apportait du
carbure
ils sont bien il n'y a pas de problème
particulier si ce n'est qu'ils sont à
l'intérieur
vers 16 heures une équipe est allée les
ravitailler ils devraient être évacués
dans le milieu de la nuit
car maintenant il faut attendre que le
niveau du siphon est suffisamment baissé
pour pouvoir les faire passer une
opération de pompage est en route en
octobre dernier neuf spéléologues
français avaient été secourues de la
même façon aujourd'hui la question de
l'absence de réglementation française
pour pratiquer la spéléo et de nouveau
soulevée retour au calme à la maison
d'arrêt de douai dans le nord les
détenus ont regagné leur cellule mais
les problèmes demeurent
reportage nos confrères de la station de
lille lui claque à bouchet et jean
pierre petit cola les 50 détenus
installés sur les toits n'ont pas envie
de discuter après avoir revendiqué la
veille pour que les conditions de
détention s'améliore cette fois il
s'attaque au fond du problème à savoir
les gros sous l'affrontement est
inévitable
l'intervention fait six blessés légers
chez les mutins mais il n'y a aucune
dégradation dans la prison une dizaine
de meneurs ont été formellement
identifiés le soir même ils étaient
transférés vers d'autres établissements
pénitentiaires
mais cela ne résout en rien les
conditions de vie des détenus a doublé
comme dans la plupart des prisons
françaises la situation est encore
explosive
puis cinq ans j'entends dire que la
terrain de football va être construit il
ya la place pour et rien n'est fait
alors il ya toujours des promesses qui
sont faites mais le problème c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent je peux et
dégâts en grosse déprime
ça fait des mois des mois ci pas des
années qu'ils attendent d'un jugement
un dossier qui traîne j'en ai qui sont à
bout au point de vue des primes quand
ils sont à bout parce que le dossier
traîne ça c'était une des causes à mon
avis aussi d'énervement meneur bombe
rien à tour partout sauf pour les
enfants de choeur 1
mais il y en a certains qui ferait mans
c'est illusoire ce à quoi des sanctions
disciplinaires voir judiciaires vont
être prises au cas par cas à l'encontre
des mutins
pourtant à l'intérieur de la prison les
conditions n'ont pas changé et la
marmite est toujours sous pression
l'administration a encore sévi et
l'histoire est forcément triste parce
qu'ils étaient retraités un homme de 85
ans ne devrait pas conserver son outil
de travail mais voilà son outil de
travail était en fait un verger 9000
cerisier pour ne pas payer une amende
il les a tous fait arracher reportage à
montpellier l'allier un hameau et jean
claude chapuis il y a peu de temps
encore le mas de bonniol était un
paradis terrestre 9000 cerisier sur 25
hectares constitué l'une des plus
grandes ceriseraie de france le maître
du domaine produisez bon an mal an 150
tonnes de ce fruit rouge pour le compte
des grands confiturier les fabricants de
kirsch
aujourd'hui les cerisiers gist à terre
comme fauché par un cyclone
un bulldozer est passée par là le
propriétaire retraité depuis 86 a été
contraints d'arracher ces arbres sous
peine de devoir continuer à régler ses
cotisations d'exploitants à la mutualité
sociale agricole s'élevant trois ans à
cent mille francs et s'est passé il
s'est passé que ces messieurs sont venus
trois mois'' appareils me dire que pour
bénéficier de la retraite et de tous ne
pas ne pas être imposables à la bsa il
fallait il y avait une loi qui disait
qu'il fallait arracher les arbres face à
l'absurdité administrative l'ex empereur
de la cerise s'est résigné à détruire
l'oeuvre de sa vie
et si un acheteur du domaine se
présenter tout pourrait alors commencer
alors je suis trop ça y est je suis âgée
j'ai dépassé la jeu mais si quelques
m'acheter qui me dis je qu'est-ce qu'il
faut planter je sais que je sais quoi
lui dire
les chemisiers le commerce extérieur se
porte plutôt mal mais celui des idéaux
plutôt celui des inventions lui se porte
bien même les inventions les plus
farfelues encore vérifié au concours
lépine est ce pas si farfelue loin de se
conclure sans sortie de nombreux objets
qui font partie de notre quotidien qui
ont changé notre vie quelques exemples
1919 le stylo à bille 1921 le fer à
repasser à vapeur 1937 le coeur
artificiel
voyez c'est étonnant je retire le bon
bah oui oui tout de suite d'un reportage
de l'édition 1990 jean paul gérard et
alain thomas porcher c'est un mouvement
pour droite et qu'on regarde aussi des
glacis les profilés à l'envers
le boomerang pour gauchers il suffisait
d'y penser ça pourrait d'ailleurs être
la devise des participants au concours
lépine ingénieurs confirmés ou géo
trouvetou du dimanche ils sacrifient
leur temps et leurs économies pour
exploiter leurs idées de génie souvent
sérieuses comme cette mallette autour et
prix gérer qui permet le transport de
sang ou de vaccins moins dramatique la
brouette pliable ou encore la ceinture
qui fait perdre le ventre par une
méthode de suggestions musicales
derrière les inventions on trouve
souvent des rêves de gosse exemple ce
casse-tête scientifique sans aucune
utilité
ça s'appelle le bozo bosso quand on
prononce le mot magique aux homos
zoologiste stock échange de 100 500
éléments se fait dire aux experts
souvenirs de mon enfance
quand j'étais jeune il y avait le dessin
animé bozo bozo et c'est en souvenir de
ça que j'ai appelé jean bozo je sais pas
si vous rappeler l'histoire de tintin et
milou le secret de rackham le rouge et
le 13h de la ligue
le secret de la licorne comme j'ai vu ça
j'avais à peu près une douzaine d'années
je me souviens un jour je ferai un sous
marin
mais attention pour un sous marin comme
pour un système à récurer les casseroles
l'idée ne suffit pas il faut aussi lui
donner une forme et les débuts sont
souvent laborieux il a fallu pas moins
de 150 prototype pour arriver à cette
petite merveille de technologie
il suffisait d'y penser et de persévérer
il allait vite très vite hier sur l'eau
à rouen et ils sont arrivés cinquante
sept bateaux de formule 3 mines étaient
au départ hier 36 seulement survécu à la
nuit l'équipage vainqueur est composé de
trois pilotes de roi hurel morin et
pujol ils ont couvert 2008 149 km le but
de ces 24 heures effectuées le plus
grand nombre de kilomètres en boucle sur
la scène trois pilotes se relayer pour
ça vole haut de leurs véritables bolides
le ticket cette épreuve et la course
d'endurance la plus longue du monde et
les chevaux galopent même le 1er mai
même le 1er mai avec un tiercé c'est un
quinté plus
le tir s'il fallait jouer le 2 le 5 le
18 qui rapportent dans l'ordre et pour
cinq francs 1870 francs dans le désordre
374 points pour le quinté plus le 2 le
cincle 18 le 11 et le set qui rapporte
pour 10 francs
213 1360 francs et dans un ordre
différent 2000 74 francs et whissell
eric fin de ce 19 20 dans quelques
instants michel touré et à 20h35 et jean
marie cavada pour la marche du siècle
war iii à 22h15 bonsoir à demain